so right over here have depicted a
square loop of a conductor let's say
it's a wire and it's stationary and it's
sitting in a magnetic field and I've
drawn a few vectors that represent the
magnetic field and you can see at least
on the surface that is defined or this
contoured by the wire that the magnetic
field looks constant so if we just had
this scenario nothing too special going
on but it becomes interesting if I were
to actually change the flux going
through the surface so both of these
pictures right over here they actually
show the same scenario where we have
increased the flux we have increased the
flux at these points on the surface
defined by the wire at every point the
magnetic field has now got gotten
stronger so we have increased the flux
so let me write that the flux we use a
Greek letter Phi to usually denote flux
the flux of the magnetic field the flux
of the magnetic field has gone up and we
know from Faraday's law that when you
have a change in your flux then that's
going to be that's going to induce a
current in the loop and so an
interesting question is what direction
is that current actually going to go in
we have two options the current could go
the current let me find a nice color for
the current the current could go in the
the current could go in the clock in the
clockwise direction or it could go in
the or it could go in the counter
clockwise direction so which of these
two do you think the current will
actually go in well let's think a little
bit about it we know that a current
flowing through a wire actually on its
own will induce a magnetic field above
and beyond the magnetic field that's
already there so let's think about the
type of magnetic field that this orange
current would would actually induce so
if it's going in the counterclockwise
direction remember we use the right hand
rule I can take my right hand point my
thumb in the direction of the current so
let me see if I can do that so my thumb
in the direction of the current and then
my hands my hands are going to loop or
as you say my fingers are going to loop
in the direction in the direction of the
magnetic field so when I do that with my
right hand so my
right hand looks something like that
thumb in the direction of the current
right over here we see that it shows a
magnetic field being induced that would
that would wrap around like that or if
we were to show it if we were to sample
it points right on the surface the
magnetic field that would be induced
would look something like this
and I'm just doing it at some sample
points so notice it would be additive it
would be additive whoops it would be it
would be it would be additive to the
existing magnetic field in fact it would
increase the flux even more in fact at
these points these vectors would
increase even more these vectors let me
see if I can draw that these vectors
would increase even more well what would
that do if the flux increases even more
than the current is going to increase
the current is going to increase even
more which is going to make the flux
increase even more and which makes the
current increase anymore and you would
have this never-ending cycle where the
current keeps increasing and the flux
keeps on increasing and you would have
this energy that's appearing out of
nowhere which would violate the law of
conservation of energy and so that's a
pretty good argument for why you would
not that's a pretty good argument for
why we would not expect the counter the
counter clockwise scenario we would not
want the current that's an induced to
induce a magnetic field that goes in the
same direction as our increase in flux
so just by deductive reasoning we know
that this is going to be the scenario
and let's see what think about what
happens here we can do the right-hand
rule again we take our right hand point
our thumb in the direction of the
current point our thumb in the direction
of the current and we see if we do that
if we do that with our right hand well
now this would this would induce a
magnetic field that would decrease the
flux so it would it would produce a
magnetic field the current right over
here would produce a magnetic field
that's going downward the current in
that direction would also when you take
your when you take your right hand and
you were to put it along here once again
if you're going in the if you are going
in the counter clockwise or sorry if
you're going in the clockwise direction
over here that to when you do your right
hand rule right over here your fingers
would coil around that way and so once
again when you look at the surface it
would produce it would induce a magnetic
field that
is going in that direction and so it
would have the induced magnetic field
from the induced current will go against
the change in flux and this makes sense
because we won't go into this
never-ending positive feedback loop
where the current keeps getting stronger
and stronger and the flux keeps
increasing and increasing and increasing
and this idea that the orientation of
the current that is induced will produce
a magnetic field that counteracts the
the the change in flux
this is Lenz's law lenses lenses law and
once again if you if that wasn't true
then you would have a violation of the
of the conservation of energy so in
general whenever someone if someone says
ok well this is the change in flux is
happening in a certain direction well to
think about which way the current would
flow you just have to say well what type
of a magnetic field would each direction
of the current produce and that magnetic
field should go in a direction that goes
against your change in flux so if the
flux is increasing the magnetic field
that's induced by the induced current
should make the flux decrease if the
flux was decreasing then the induced
magnetic field by the induced current
should make the flux decrease less or
should make the flux should be additive
to the flux